This video has been brought to you by Wix and we'll show you how they helped us
make a new periodic table. Later in the episode,
everyone knows that men delayed invented the periodic table,
but did he really invent it?
We here to find out we here in some Catherine's college,
Cambridge where the well-known chemist,
Peter Waters has assembled unique collection of early books about the
periodic table,
including I believe some real treasures from mental lives output.
Let's go in and see what he's got. Well.
Uh, most people would expect us to begin with Mandelos first periodic table.
So this features in volume,
one of his textbook and system of chemistry here. And it was literally,
this is just added in at the beginning.
So this is the first published periodic table. Wow. Which is really rather nice.
So how has your rush? And then you can, you can read this. Okay, good.
Just an so it's based on their atomic weight and
the chemical properties.
So this is a system of the elements kind of commitments.
So of course the immediately a noticeable first thing is it's the wrong way.
Round from our modern periodic table.
Mendeleev has arranged his groups horizontally in this, which is fine.
So for instance, we see lithium sodium potassium, rubidium cesium.
Now he's got this one wrong.
Is there any elements that didn't exist?
Um, yes, there is, uh, somewhere to Damien, would we say it doesn't exist,
but of course was resolved. Exactly.
Explain to me what's the book and why did he wait until the last minute for the
best part.
He was writing a textbook of inorganic chemistry and he'd already written volume
one, and this would actually already been printed. And it was,
as he was beginning to write further parts of this, he thought, well,
where am I going to go next in the, well, we won't say the periodic table.
Cause there wasn't one. But after discussing related elements, you thought,
well, which, which, which set of elements should I do next?
So he wanted to come up with a system and this is his system,
but the books were already printed this, this first volume. And so this,
a few leaves here were just sent in to literally be stuck in,
to be pasted in to the printed books, which is remarkable.
This is rather a nice copy actually, because it was,
I think the first owner was a lady, uh, perhaps one of his students.
Somebody has made notes.
Yes. I'm not quite sure what these are yet.
I'm going to have to work through that. It is quite a rare book or at least, uh,
we don't know how many copies that are outside of Russia.
We think this is the only copy in the UK.
So I mentioned that the groups in this are arranged horizontally,
but in the second volume, which came out two years later,
he's he's changed this,
he's rearranged his periodic table to be far more
recognizable to our eyes. Uh, now this one is,
is rather tricky and Franchelle it's um,
so this is in the beginning of volume, two of his book. Uh,
so now you see we hydrogen lithium, sodium potassium, rubidium,
cesium going vertically down.
So this looks much more like our modern periodic table and what.
Is this extra bit here? Okay. He.
Developed lots of different arrangements actually. Um,
and so this is also quite good. I mean, it looks like a period of time.
So some of group to appear here and some of the here, um,
so magnesium is over here, uh, as opposed to in the group here,
similarly with Sodiomon so on, he had group, um, one,
a and one B um, with the, and there's some sense to this is of course,
as you know,
I think the fact that this is now a rather more extensive fold-out chart
just shows the importance that he attached to this, uh, to his system.
And obviously this is what he's absolutely famous for. Now.
He's written here is the natural system of the elements
and he's put his name for it. So, I mean,
he's really gluing his name to the periodic table straight away.
He really did this actually. So this is,
I think one of the reasons why mender laugh is often cited as the discover of
the periodic table. He really promoted this.
He says it was his discovery that the system, the law or the periodic law,
but there were other people as we shall see. So this was his first textbook.
And I say it came out in two volumes, usually published in two volumes,
although it came out perhaps in four, um,
and this second volume was two years after the very first table that we saw,
but actually he did publish a more extensive, um,
journal article where he really describes the periodic system of this apparently
was only printed in 80 copies. So now we really are quite lucky to have,
have one of these here.
So this is the very first volume of the Russian chemical society,
the journal of the Russian chemical society. So this then is Mandela,
F's real first announcement of his periodic table and the system.
So this is, uh, the discovery of the periodic law as he called it.
And obviously he realized that there was something quite fundamental behind this
and perhaps the reason why his table and system
caught on more than others is because he was also predicting properties
of the, and it's very detailed predictions.
And that's perhaps some of the other discoveries didn't go into the same level
of detail that he did,
but we see exactly the same table that we saw in the textbook. Yes.
Now I think what's really fun is, uh, so we see this amazing discovery,
this amazing announcement to see the first report of this in English. Okay.
And this was from, uh, from this,
this the same year and it's in, um, the chemical news.
Now this was a publication by William Crookes.
He was the editor of discovered a family of of course. And it was,
it was said that he just reported anything,
absolutely everything that was ever sort of anything chemical appeared in here.
And so in here we have, uh,
this here is the very first announcement in English of mental layers
system. Can you read the, yes. It says, uh, atomic weights,
Mendel F this paper contains a new of grouping, the elements,
according to the numerical value of their atomic weights in the following
manner. Now you have to listen carefully here.
So lithium seven beryllium 9.4 boron, 11 carbon,
12 nitrogen, 14 oxygen. He's given the symbols here. So, Oh,
16 than Effie 19 at eight 23.
So they even get the order wrong.
There's a misprint where they put the symbol for iron instead of which
I think is wonderful, isn't it? But that's it.
This tiny little paragraph here is, is this the first announcement of the day?
And it was completely overlooked really at the time.
Nobody really took much notice of this. And this was because I think, well,
people really took notice when the first elements were discovered that agree
with his predictions. So he says at the end here,
the author points out that this grouping of the elements expresses the law.
According to which the elements can combine with oxygen.
As you see this publication then in the chemical use was in, uh, December the,
uh, is that the 10th, 1869. So it the same.
Yes, but it's took quite a long time from March to December. Yes.
But this is because they were picking up these entries in other foreign
journals, as they say here, as they describe it.
But what I think is particularly nice. So it says, um,
the author points out that this grouping of the elements, well,
they don't actually show any grouping in this cause they just give the first
line of his table.
But it also shows that more senior chemists are
notorious for not recognizing breakthroughs when they happen.
And absolutely it's, haven't changed.
So while we're on Mandela, I thought I'd show you this. This is rather nice.
So this has been described as his master's thesis, this,
this tiny little pamphlet here,
there's evidence that he's thinking of atomic weights and organization of things
in here. We see lots of nice formula, different compounds.
So it says here that it was chosen for the defense of the degree of master of
chemistry.
Uh huh.
In some bibliographies you see this is described as his thesis,
but it turns out that this is just the synopsis and I'm delighted that we
also have the whole thesis here, which is really nice.
And we haven't found another copy of this recorded in any library to take,
there must be copies in Russia, of course, but, uh,
we haven't found any others yet. So I think he's looking for specific volumes.
So these are essentially what we would now call molar volumes of compounds.
And again, this is starting thinking about looking for trends and patterns here.
When did I've went through eight different additions of his textbook.
And of course he had to introduce a whole new group with the noble gases.
These don't feature in the first, but I think this one is rather fun.
So I think this is his last, it's not an edition of his textbook,
but it does contain his last periodic table published in a remarkable journal.
It's, it's crazy in a serialized form in this journal with all sorts of
strange articles in. So this, as I say,
this really is quite an odd thing to find this final periodic table in here.
And so this was,
I think his last version of the periodic table,
but he made a slight error here because he puts the noble gases in as
group zero, which makes perfect sense. It's the, uh,
the vacancy is zero,
but this meant then he put helium just before lithium.
And then this therefore suggested with hydrogen above lithium,
that there might be another element of helium and one more
above hydrogen.
So he has X and Y there's two unknown elements. Now one of these,
it was thought had been discovered in the sun. This was coronial,
which it turns out to be a highly oxidized iron of iron.
But the other one he thought was, um, undiscovered.
And he proposed the name Newtonian, which I think is rather nice,
which brings us back to Cambridge.
Well,
you could argue that the neutron should go there and they've got at least one
periodic table that has neutron on it.
So you could pop in the neutron there if you wanted, you could.
This is the fourth edition of his textbook,
where the first periodic table appeared, but this is an amazing copy.
This is actually a presentation copy from Mandalay.
This was presented to the Scottish chemist, Alexander Crum Brown,
who was one of the people who developed organic structures.
Yes. I've heard of him. He did he read Russian or.
Well, yes, that's a good question. Actually. I don't know. Mental laugh,
visited Crum Brown in Edinburgh
to receive an honorary degree. So this was at that time. So it's,
it's dated there at 1884, which is really rather lovely. Isn't it?
How much is that work? I have no idea how much this would be worth now,
but it's, it's really quite fun.
So this is the version of the periodic table that appears in here.
Interestingly enough, this one page, uh,
appeared at auction last week, um, in Christie's, uh,
it was also signed by Mandela F like our book is,
and it's sold for over 20,000 pounds.
20,000 Pounds for one page. Yes. So how many pages you've got to? Yeah.
I think we could extrapolate like that, but I think this,
this complete volume would be quite pricey. Yeah.
Now I want to go back to Mandalay S first published periodic table.
So this was the one from 1869.
And the reason I want to do this is because I want you to see another one from
an English chemist called William Oberlin.
So this is five years earlier. So this is from 1864. So for instance,
we have sodium potassium, rubidium Caesium.
Now he's put lithium wrong symbol up here. And of course,
Mandalay F gets his includes lithium here, but for group two,
we have glue Sinia. So the old name for beryllium, uh, and lead here.
And then we have magnesium, calcium strontium and barium,
and group two. We have beryllium magnesium.
So they're separate from the other members, calcium strontium, barium.
And again, what's led in the same group, understandably,
but when we go to compare some of the other groups in the main group,
the they get even closer to the similarities.
So group three or 13 of the periodic tables is a tricky one because of course
they only had a couple of elements.
So Mandalay only knew of boron and Allie minium. So we have boron, Alli, minium,
unknown, and uranium, and gold from a mental layers.
And here we have boron, Alli minium, a space again, where gallium will come.
And then again, uranium. So they're really very,
very similar these tables when we go to, um,
group 15 or five nitrogen phosphorous, arsenic,
and to many bismuth completely right in Oberlin's table and completely right in
Mondelez, nitrogen phosphorous, arsenic, antimony bismuth.
So where did he publish this?
So this is in, um, a journal with it's not to chemical journal.
So this is the journal of science.
So there are many different articles in this from related subjects,
but he didn't really push this in the same way that Mendeleev did later.
And he didn't really, um,
produce such accurate predictions for the properties of the missing elements.
And that was the thing that really caught people's attention.
And what did he call this? His article?
I th I think it's just an arrangement. So the,
the title of his article is on the proportional numbers.
Of the elements, but so he was quite an eminent scientist.
He was a fellow of the Royal society. Yes.
It shows that you've not only got to discover something or
propose something, but other people have to find out, but it's,
and if you publish it somewhere, when nobody else sees it,
then you might as well not publish it at all. So what's his name? William,
when you must say that EarthLink does not have the sound of rain delay of
snakes.
It's interesting that the groups also are going horizontally as well,
like mental Ava's first version professor Poliakoff.
Did you know about this poll today?
I, I knew that there were some previous ones,
but I never realized how similar it was.
Don't you think that perhaps the reason they go horizontally,
because it's easier from the point of view, putting it in the book,
you don't have to change the landscape format of the page.
But then again, of course, I mean the,
so the arrangement by mass is now going vertically downward.
So if something's going to go down and something's going to go across,
if this was five years before,
isn't it conceivable that Mengele have saw this and it inspired his arrangement.
It is possible that bender LEF, uh, may have seen this. It was,
I think this was translated into Russian, not by him,
but he says he wasn't aware of it. He was asked about it.
Was it? Yeah. Yeah. But,
and this is not the only British chemist who developed the periodic table.
Perhaps more famous is Newlands and his law of octaves.
Now eventually Newlands really wanted to try to establish some claim to the
periodic table. So he published this lovely little book, um,
where all of his collected journal articles were assembled together.
And now I have one of the original ones to show you in a moment, but this is,
this is a nice copy. So this is, uh, to, uh, Greenville Williams. He was,
uh, one of the people that worked with crooks in the discovery of thallium. So,
uh, crux mentions him at the end of his paper, which is rather nice.
So this shows, uh, his attempts at, um, coming up with a periodic table,
but these were initially published in the chemical, um, news.
And so this is the first version of Newland's
announcement when he's looked beginning to look for relationships between the
atomic masses. So, um,
this is in here on relations among the equivalents
in this version, he's looking for, um, relationship between the,
what we would now call atomic weights. Um,
some of them are out by a factor of two,
and this is because they just were not known at the time.
So many of these look wrong to us, so they are halved. So magnesium 12, oxygen,
eight, a and so on, but some of them are correct. So lithium seven,
fluorine 19.
And nitrogen 14.
So his first table, though, we see, um, comes a little bit later,
here are some of his early tables. So again,
this one is going across. So we have hydrogen fluorine, chlorine,
and bromine and iodine.
So this is very similar to Mendel laughs version. And this is,
this particular one is from 18, six.
Did live, was he also asked about Newland's work?
Uh, mental life just said that his version was very different and that he really
discovered the, the periodic law. So interestingly,
most of the copies of this that I've seen, um, are signed by the author.
So actually one of those books where it's the very rare copy that isn't signed
by the author,
but this was because he was trying to promote his system to show that he had a
sense of priority for the defense.
So what is this table here?
You take it out in case I damage it.
Um, so the elements in order of atomic weight, horizontal arrangement. So again,
this is, um, this is fairly similar to Mendel lives. Uh, what, uh,
Newlands noticed of course is that when the elements are arranged,
when we come to the, uh, by order of that atomic weights,
as they were known at the time, um, when you come to the eighth element, uh,
in the order, we have something with similar properties. And so this was his,
his, his discovery, and why he called it the law of octane,
because of course it's similar with the notes on the piano.
It's when you go eight up, you get to a similar related note,
but of course also missing from this because they were not discovered at the
time with the Nobel gasses. And this means when you include those,
it will be every ninth element so that it would be the lore of nanos.
This is really very interesting.
So these are all quite fun,
but actually what I'm going to show you now is regarded as perhaps the
very first periodic table. And do you know who this is by? No, no.
This is a French mineralogist called Alexandra Ameel Baguio Shankar
tour. And that one definitely doesn't roll off the tongue. Now,
before I show you his table, I shall show you, uh,
we're fortunate enough to have this. This is a collection of his off prints,
and this was given to one of his colleagues and he included
a, a photograph. So this is actually a photograph of, uh, Baguio Deshaun,
Courtois, and signed by him, which is rather nice, his arrangement,
this nobody knows of him, and it really didn't catch on,
but this was seven years before Mandela F's version.
The reason this did not catch on is because, well,
for starters, he was a mineralogist.
So it wasn't really being read by the chemists of the day.
But the main reason is he published this in a journal with no diagram.
So there is no, there was no table in the original journal version. However,
um, he also had some off pins may as he did in the, in those days. Uh,
so these were separate printings of the article. And with this,
he did have a, um, an illustration made and this one,
I need to have some space here. So let's open this out.
And this is the reason that it,
nobody knew of it because it couldn't be included in the publication because
this is so large.
So you can see why.
The, the publishers were reluctant to include this in the journal article.
So this is printed on card in, in, uh, it's got red, black,
and green colors in it, and it's about five foot long,
but now what we're looking at here, so what do we need for a periodic table?
We need all of the elements to be arranged in order of that
within this case, atomic weights, because of course,
nobody had any idea of atomic number at this time.
And so these are all the elements arranged according to their atomic weight.
And we need to look for the repeating patterns, and this is the way he's done.
This is, these are arranged. This should be a cylinder. So at the top here,
we have a view from above of a cylinder. Again, we're going round,
um, 16 units around here.
And so this would be 16 atomic weight units, atomic mass units.
And then we come to an element with a similar property.
So this is going to be arranged on a, on a it'll form, a helix.
So this has been wound round the, the cylinder here. So for instance,
we have here is lithium,
and then he found that elements with similar properties are aligned in the
vertical columns. So we have lithium here, sodium potassium,
and then if we go a bit further down rubidium.
That is amazing. I've never, I have not heard of him.
I've never seen anything like this. And it's extraordinary.
This is really rather rare because this was only in the off prints,
not in the journal. So this is actually a signed copy again.
So this was presentation copy from, um, uh,
Baguio here and it's the survival of these charts. And he also changed these.
So this we think is the very, very first version.
So it says at the top of the 7th of April, 1862,
and there are slightly later versions where he modified this.
And so added a later date underneath where he just tweaked things because the
real problem with this is, is what,
what were the atomic weights of the elements?
And this is where the problem came. And so actually we see on the table,
Silicon and Silicon is also here. And, uh,
it's on here a third time as well, somewhere. So it's mentioned three times.
And this is because he wasn't entirely sure what the mass,
the atomic weight of Silicon should be. And this was because they,
they understood that a certain massive one element combined with a certain
massive another, but they didn't know what the formula for a product was.
So we now know that when you combine Silicon and oxygen,
you have Silicon dioxide, but they didn't know this.
They knew that a certain masses combined.
And so depending on what the formula for Silicon oxide is Silicon silica,
this would give rise to different masses, but include modeling, which is great.
Do you think Mandela gets too much credit? Is history written wrong is history,
right? What does this make you feel? I don't know what to walk away thinking.
Wow.
I think you cannot alter history because
sometimes two people or more discover something,
but one of them has a more profound influence than the others.
And so you can't, it's not enough to say I discovered this first,
you've got to look and see what influence you had on people that came
after you. And sadly,
sometimes it's not the first person that has the real influence,
particularly because the second person may get a bit more momentum
from knowing that somebody else has had a similar idea. So first of all,
pushing their idea harder,
but they also have a bit more confidence in their idea.
I think it's,
it's no coincidence that actually six different scientists from around the world
all independently came up with their versions of what we would now call the
periodic table, um, all in the 1860s.
And perhaps it's not surprising that one of them is going to be much more famous
than the others. I think deservedly. So, I mean,
mental life did push things slightly further with his very accurate predictions
of missing elements. And that's really what caught people's attention.
Okay. So I want to show you another periodic table.
This is one we've put online. It's at periodic videos.net,
and we've built it using Wix, which is the sponsor of today's episode.
Wix is a powerful, elegant tool that can help people at all levels.
Even me make amazing websites, whether it's business or a personal site,
or maybe just something in between, get on Wix, get creating. It's free,
highly customizable. As you can see here, as I tweak our site,
you can start with a template and then just take it in whatever direction you
want. It's drag and drop really intuitive. And there are loads of options.
You can just change everything, get it just how you want it.
If you do want to check them out, go to the URL,
wix.com/go/periodic videos.
It's on the screen.
That'll let them know you came from here and that helps us as well. Hey,
once you've got your own site up and running,
why not drop us an email so we can see what you did that address again,
wix.com/go/periodic videos.
There's also a link in the description.
Spit. Um, saliva is actually used in conservation all the time.
It's a really gentle cleaning agent. It's 99% water enzymes,
and it's the enzymes that break down the dirt. So, wow.
You weren't joking under the tongue. Is this like a known blood technique?
Let's do a little section here. This is kind of gross.